our goal for madden NFL 15 was to
redefine the way you play defense to
deliver gameplay that is fun and
exciting while giving you the ability to
control the pace of any game like never
before for the first time in the madden
franchise you can see defensive gameplay
from an all new perspective went on
defense pressing up on the d-pad will
activate the new defensive camera angle
putting you right in the action to lock
onto a specific players in the defensive
camera you press the L free button the
core football starts at the line of
scrimmage warned the trenches in madden
25 overhauled the offensive line plan
giving the big men up front intelligence
to work as a team and create authentic
passing pockets now with war in the
trenches to point o madden 15 we've
redesigned the defensive side of the
ball giving you the tools you need to be
a constant threat once the ball is
snapped you only have a few seconds to
get to the quarterback so your jump off
the line is very important pull the
right trigger when perfectly time with
the snap you'll receive a small boost
off the line giving you the advantage
over closing offensive lineman but be
careful poorly timed jump could result
in a loss of balance getting pancaked or
even worse an encroachment once you
engage with the offensive lineman after
the snap
most of you defensive moves at your
fingertips use the left stick to steer
an offensive lineman to old gaps close
up running lanes or get an offensive
lineman off balance to set up for a pass
rusher in controlling a power defensive
lineman like JJ Watt or no Donna can sue
press square to perform a Power Move
based on the ability to lineman you see
contextual power pass rush move like
grips bull rushes and many other paths
residents
when controlling a speed pass rusher
like Jadeveon Clowney or cameron wait
press the x button would engage the
blocker to perform contextual finesse
moves like spans and swims knowing the
type of pass rusher you are controlling
how to shift the momentum of the
offensive lineman and reading the
quarterback will help you control the
line of scrimmage and dominate the wall
in the trenches pick up madden 15 in
stores August 26 and experience it for
yourself